soire a lieu à 20h la présentation au
public de la nouvelle saison alors nous
avons rencontré en avant-première son
directeur Jacques Pornon qui malgré un
choix difficile nous a quand même livré
ses ses coups de cœur parmi les 44
spectacles pas mal de choses autour de
l'Opéra dire que la création de coi van
chulli c'est quelque chose qu'on attend
avec impatience par que c'est une
création
musicale de Nicolas Baker sur un texte
de er schmi avec l'opéra foco qui est
artiste en résidence depuis depuis
longtemps j'attends avec impatience
aussi le le retour d'une flute de Peter
Brook qui a eu déjà beaucoup de succès
et c'est pour ça qu'on le qu'on le
reprend dans le domaine théâtral il y a
pas mal de créations notamment le par
les village de peterque qui va être mis
en scène par sal Sordet qui est une qui
va faire l'ouverture du Festival
d'Avignon on aura la chance puisquon est
partenaire de ce projet de l'accueillir
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on a envie
de de de défendre et de de et et qu'on
va attendre avec impatience et puis dans
un autre registre peut-être le
Misanthrope mis en scène par
Jean-François civadier qui présente ce
spectacle dans nos murs avec une
distribution remarquable et et c'est la
première fois que Jean-François civadier
fait une présente une mise en scène à 50
an lielin je peux peut-être quand même
rajouter le Ubu de docllan donelan qui
sera joué bien sûr en français avec les
acteurs français mis en scène par ce
grand metteur en scène britannique qui
qui lui aussi viendra pour la première
fois présenter ce ce travail dans le
domaine du cirque dire quand même un mot
d'écolepteur puisqu'il s'agit d'une
coproduction avec les autres lieux de
l'agglomération de saubine qui sera sur
la base de loisir de de Trapp et c'est
une création pour lequel d'ailleurs
l'agglomération est partenaire de ce de
ce projet et qui va être un moment très
très fort de de aussi de de partage avec
avec un très large un très large public
la programmation elle a à la fois une
dimension festive une dimension aussi de
de de connaissance de découverte de de
du plaisir on va dire de la de la
rencontre et de la nouveauté et et de ce
point de vue-là je pense que ça les
60000 spectateurs qui nous font
confiance et qui qui continuent de de de
venir et c'est des chiffres records de
fréquentation montrre que il faut il
faut aller voir sur le site je pense que
c'est peut-être une manière aussi de de
de découvrir plus au-delà des des mots
de découvrir le le le contenu des des
spectacles
alors le le le théâtre pardon faête ses
20 ans en septembre en l'occurrence et
donc à cette occasion un blog est mis en
place et donc le théâtre invite le
public à y déposer photos souvenirs tout
ce qui att trait donc au théâtre et qui
viendrait créer une sorte de mémoire
virtuelle un musée vivant donc pour cela
rendez-vous en effet sur le site du
théâtre dès demain par contre dès demain
blog qui sera mis en place voilà à
l'occasion des 20 ans exactement et
alors toujours au théâtre parce qu'il
s'y passe beaucoup de choses à
Saint-Quentin
vendredi aura lieu un concert autour des
aires emblématiques de Mozart interprété
par 250 enfants ce sont des enfants
issus des écoles ivelinoises nous avons
nous les avons suivi au cours de de
répétition on
regarde sous la direction musicale de
David Stern et sa compagnie opéra fouo
le théâtre de CTIN en yelg présente le 7
juin un concert des air les plus
emblématiques de Mozart interprété par
250 enfants issu d'école primaire et
collège des ivelines ils deviennent le
temps d'une représentation de vrais
choristes j'aime bien chanter je trouve
que c'est bien en plus on apprend plein
de chants et c'est facile à apprendre on
commence à les répéter puis après on les
apprend chez nous de temps en temps dans
ma chambre je chante un peu d'opéra
comme ça peu habitué à écouter des aires
d'opéra nos jeunes chanteurs travaillent
depuis plusieurs mois répétition en
classe et sur la scène du Grand Théâtre
un projet qui demande un réel
investissement on arrive dans avec des
enfants sur des secteurs difficiles et
qui sont qui deviennent passionnés et
voilà ça vient aussi de l'enseignant qui
est très très moteur dans une dans une
classe on leur a expliqué l'histoire de
chaque a d'opéra ils sont venus au
théâtre c'est bien aussi qu'on vienne
dans leur milieu ils sont contents qu'on
vienne dans leur classe et ils nous
montrent aussi tout tr on fait aour de
Mo en l'occurrence pour cette année non
c'est passionnant
ou les enfants sont motivés ça faitdère
le
groupe ils deviennent beaucoup plus
concentrés ils sont attentifs ils sont
attentifs au moindre petit petites
remarqu donc ça en classe pour les
apprentissages ça apporte beaucoup
curieusement même si les paroles sont en
italien ou en allemand ils ont eu
beaucoup de facilité à les apprendre
plus que l'Étap de multiplication ou les
conjugaisons et à partir du moment où
ils sont dans le projet et qu's sont
heureux d'y participer ils ont une
faculté de de mémoriser beaucoup plus
que les adultes ça passe tout seul la
mise en place de ce projet est pour le
théâtre l'occasion de démocratiser
l'accès à l'art lyrique dans le cadre de
son programme opéra pour tous soyez
généreux d'accord so généreux faites-le
pour le public pour vous pour l'objectif
étant évidemment au travers de ce projet
de faire des jeunes gens des spectateurs
avertis avant tout hein c'est de leur
donner des clés pour apprécier au mieux
les œuvres et les œuvres d'opéra
notamment et et évidemment l'idée
l'objectif c'est d'en faire de de de
futurs spectateurs de futurs spectateurs
autonome dans leur pratique hein on
pourrait imaginer c'est le cas année
après année on se rend compte que nombre
d'enfants reviennent avec leurs parents
dans une pratique individuelle une
pratique de plaisir de loisir et on est
Rav
fillere fille moi je cherche mes
enfs